maybe for you there's a tomorrow but for  some of us there is only today okay  exactly  get in no I'm eating yeah well you guys  big party like I mom's going out of town  oh my god  what you doing here what's this what are  you doing  what happened last night what do you  happy that I've been having deja vu all  day long  are you okay it wasn't a dream it really  happened again  the only way to escape is to change  watch out for the dress wet top I have  to do something that would make a  difference  maybe things could change and maybe I  could change them  [Music]  number two we are you in trouble you can  trust me  [Music]  maybe for you there's that tomorrow but  for some of us they will make today but  I didn't know any of that until right  before I  you